all the facts must be established all
those responsible for these atrocities
must be brought to justice
and allies are supporting efforts for an
international investigation
ukrainian foreign minister dimitro
coleba thanked nato allies uh for their
substantial support
allies have been doing a lot
and are determined to do more
now and for the medium and longer term
to help the brave ukrainians defend
their homes and their country and push
back the invading forces
allies are also supporting
and stepping up humanitarian aid and
financial support
we discussed what more we will do
including cyber security assistance
and providing equipment to help ukraine
protect against chemical and biological
threats
allies agreed that we should also
help other partners to strengthen their
resilience and shore up their ability to
defend themselves
including georgia and bosnia herzegovina
for georgia we could increase our
support through the substantial nato
georgia package
including in areas like situational
awareness
secure communications and cyber
for bosnia and natsugovana we could
develop a new defense capacity building
package
any assistance would be tailored demand
driven and delivered with the full
consent of the countries concerned
today
we're also joined by georgia finland
sweden and the european union
as well as nato's asia-pacific partners
australia japan
new zealand and the republic of korea
because the implications of russia's
invasions are global
and will be long-lasting
and what is happening in ukraine is
being closely watched around the world
we have seen that china is unwilling to
condemn russia's aggression
and beijing has joined moscow in
questioning the right of nations to
choose their own path
this is a serious challenge to us all
and it makes it even more important that
we stand together to protect our values
nate and our asia-pacific partners have
now agreed to step up our practical and
political cooperation in several areas
including cyber
new technology
and countering this information
we will also work more closely
together in other areas such as maritime
security
climate change
and resilience
because global challenges demand global
solutions
ministers also addressed our future
relations with russia
the sanctions introduced by nato allies
and our partners are unprecedented
and they are
damaging president putin's war machine
we need to continue
coordinated pressure to help end this
senseless war
ministers agreed that nato's next
strategic concept must deliver a
response on how we relate to russia in
the future
and for the first time
it must also take account of how china's
growing influence and coercive policies
affect our security
the strategic concept will be finalized
for the madrid summit in june
it will be the road map for the
alliance's continued adaptation for the
more dangerous and competitive world we
live in
finally allies approved the charter for
our defense innovation accelerator for
the north atlantic or diana
to start it will include a network of
around 60 innovation sites in north
america and europe
working with the private sector academia
allies will ensure that we can harness
the best of new technology for
transatlantic security and with that i'm
ready to take your questions
we'll start with also journal
second row
thank you thank you very much dan
michaels wall street journal um minister
koleba said this morning and this
afternoon that his
agenda here was weapons weapons weapons
and this afternoon said he needs the
ukraine needs them faster he's concerned
about the speed of the delivery of the
weapons um what can you say about what
you and the nato partners are doing to
accelerate deliveries if if that is the
case and especially since as you have
said as he said the scale of the
fighting is
that looks set to happen in donbass
we'll just be on a whole nother level
from what we've seen before is ukraine
ready for that kind of fight thank you
let me just start by reminding everyone
on that uh nato allies and nato have
supported ukraine for many years
after the illegal annexation of crimea
and russia's first invasion in 2014
uh also into donbas
uh nato allies and nato have provided
significant support with
equipment with training tens of
thousands of ukrainian soldiers have
been trained
and then uh
when we saw the intelligence indicating
uh a highly likely invasion allies
stepped up last autumn and uh
this winter then off the
invasion allies have stepped up with
additional military support with more
military equipment and it was a clear
message from the meeting today that
allies
should do more and are ready to do more
to provide more equipment and they
realize and and recognize the urgency so
this is actually one of the reasons why
it was important to have
minister coleba at the meeting
and we are closely
coordinating uh working with also
discussing these issues with the with um
with
ukraine and of course the different
meetings we have helps us also to be uh
informed about their needs so allies are
providing uh and they're ready to do
more when it comes to military support
al jazeera
i'm step faster from al jazeera english
you speak about more weapons right does
it mean in quantity or are you talking
about a different kind of weapon more as
we call it in a more offensive weapon
and how do you think russia was is going
to respond to that that's my first
question and secondly i would like to
ask your comments on this video that has
emerged where
ukrainian forces appear to be killing
russian
soldiers that have been captured already
thank you very much
i i fully uh
understand that you are asking specific
questions about specific types of
weapons
at the same time uh i i think it's
important to understand that
allies
believe
it is better often to not be specific
exactly
about what kind of systems
but
but rest assured allies are providing a
wide range of different weapon systems
both
soviet era systems but also modern
equipment
and i think that this distinction
between offensive and defensive is a bit
strange because we speak about providing
weapons to a country which is defending
itself
and and self-defense
is a right which is enshrined in the eu
in charter so
everything ukraine does
with the support from nato allies is
defensive because they are defending
themselves
uh and uh and of course they need
different types of weapons
and allies are providing them with
different types of weapons and we see
the impact
of these weapons on the background
every day
because the ukrainians have been able to
inflict severe
losses on the invading russian
forces
then i would say that
every report on
potential violations of
of
national law
should be
thoroughly uh looked into
and of course any evaluation of
of international law and any war crime
is always unacceptable but i cannot
comment on that specific video because i
don't know anything about that specific
incident
yes sir thank you very much
um
one more question about weapons i'm not
asking what when and how of course not
i'm not asking about those specifics but
can you say
uh
the
so to say
the line within nato are there any
exclusions of the types of weapons that
nato allies are ready to provide as we
heard
a couple of weeks ago during the nato
summit like macron was saying that tanks
and jets are out of the question or can
you say that now there are no exclusions
of the types of systems that can be
provided to ukraine thank you very much
so again if i start to be specific uh in
my answers to that type of questions i
actually said a lot about what kind of
systems we are delivering on nato allies
are are delivering so
again
the important thing is that nato allies
are providing
significant military support
to ukraine
but also humanitarian support financial
support and lethal and non-lethal
support we have done that for many years
and allies have now stepped up
then
the
what what is important to also underline
is that
nato allies provide support to ukraine
at the same time nato's
main responsibility is to protect and
defend all allies
and
and to prevent this
conflict from escalating to a
full-fledged war
between
nato and
russia
and that's reason why we also
are focused on how to
manage
the risk of escalation
and also to send a clear message that we
are there to defend and protect all
allies not to provoke a conflict but to
prevent the conflict and the reason why
we have over the last weeks uh
deployed 40 000 troops on the direct
nato command
to the eastern part alliance and also
added more uh troops under national
command including uh
more u.s troops in europe and and this
presence is to help prevent escalation
of the conflict so we are
preventing escalation nato will not be
directly involved in the conflict
nato allies will not send troops
or capabilities
into
ukraine
but at the same time we are providing
support to ukraine in many different
ways
we'll go to uh hbo the lady in white
yeah
how the u.s and secretary blinken
have been approaching this week and why
is
a long call for this war an assumption
why not just do everything you can now
while russia retreats
the easiest way to end this war is for
president putin to pull back all his
troops and to end the war and to sit
down and engage in
in serious uh
diplomatic efforts to find a solution
but we need to be realistic and we have
no indications that uh president putin
has changed his over
uh uh
overall goal and that is to
control uh
ukraine and to
and to achieve significant military
victories on the battleground
so uh we don't see a russian retreat
why we
what we see is a russian
regrouping and repositioning of their
forces
moving out of
northern ukraine
but at the same time moving those forces
to the east and we expect
a big
battle
in donbas a big russian offensive
and that's the reason why allies also
highlighted today the urgency of
providing more
support to
to ukraine and that was also the message
of course from minister coleba
so
that's also the reason why we need uh to
of course work for
uh a quick end to this war and that's
the reason why also allahs are imposing
heavy costs on uh on president putin and
russia
but at the same time be prepared for a
long haul this war may last for
weeks but also months and
possibly also for years and therefore we
need to prepare for a long haul
emedi in green
thank you so much mr secretary general
you mentioned a strategic concept uh
2030 which will be a road map for this
organization that's why this document is
very very important for georgia
what should we expect i mean open door
about open door policy about the future
of aspirants and can you tell us more
about uh meeting with georgian foreign
affairs minister thank you so much
the georgian minister foreign affairs
attended the meeting today and for me it
was a pleasure uh to meet him and to and
to talk to him uh we had also a
bilateral uh meeting and and i think it
is important that
we have close contacts with
georgia and also the new minister
foreign affairs
that demonstrates the strength and the
importance of the partnership between
georgia and
and nato and we also
are working on how to further strengthen
our partnership including
by
improving and strengthening the
package we have already agreed and to
add more to that package including
issues related to secure communications
resilience and cyber so
we
[Music]
look into how we can
further strengthen both the political
and the practical cooperation and
partnership with georgia
well in the strategic concept uh
that will be agreed in uh at the
summit in madrid but i expect allies
will agree that nato's door remains
open and also that allies will agree on
the importance of further strengthening
uh to work with partners including those
partners like georgia who which are
under pressure
from russia and uh and to step up the
cooperation and uh and supported to
those partners
mr secretary general we just heard the
foreign minister kuliba here offering an
understanding with nato that if you
support us with all we need we shall
fight for
our security but also their security
that is nato security so
well our understanding uh and the
message from all allies is that we are
ready and nato allies
are ready to provide support to ukraine
and also provide more support and
allies
recognize the urgency of
providing more
support and that was the main message
from allies today
at the same time of course nato has a
core responsibility to ensure uh
collective defense to the to ensure a
credible deterrence
and we have done that
for more than 70 years
but after the
russian invasion of ukraine in 2014 we
have
significantly stepped up our presence in
the eastern part of alliance we tripled
the size of the nato response force for
the first time in our history we
deployed combatanted troops to the east
eastern part of the alliance
and and we have increased defence
spending across
the alliance and then
after the second invasion after what we
saw on the 24th of february six weeks
ago from today um
we have further stepped up with
thousands of more troops backed by
substantial naval and air capabilities
so so so
uh
we
are ensuring credible deterrence and at
the same time
supporting ukraine because
uh ukraine of course the bravery that
courage the
the commitment both of the ukrainian
armed forces but also the ukrainian
people and the
ukrainian political leadership
um
have inspired us all and
and
and
it is extremely important that we
continue to support them okay right
thank you marilu lucrezia
secretary general what is the risk for
nato if the war will be very long
thank you
if the war is going to drag on and
belong
then the risk is first and foremost for
the people of ukraine who will suffer
more who will see more damage more death
and more destruction
so this is first and foremost a tragedy
for them
and the responsibility for president
putin to end this war to withdraw its
troops and engage in serious political
efforts to find a political settlement
but of course as long as the war
continues
there will be a risk for escalation
beyond ukraine and that's exactly what
nato is focused on is to prevent that
escalation
and we are focused on
prevention or to prevent escalation
partly by
making sure that allies
deliver the same message and stay united
uh but also by
increasing the presence
uh in the in the eastern part alliance
in particular
we have done a lot already but at the
summit we had
recently here in brussels with all the
nato and society government the heads of
state and government uh agreed to ask
our military commanders to provide
options for more longer-term
changes
in our military posture to to to address
the long-term effects of this war
because regardless of whether this war
ends within weeks months or years
it will have long-term effects
on our security
on
the way nato nato needs to respond and
ensure continued collective defense and
safety and security for nato allies
okay thank you very much this is all we
have time for
thank you